[Music]
what makes me what what makes me cry
what makes me cry it makes me cry Oh
like legitimately crying buzz it's a
hard case can I like in real life my
wife is pregnant so whenever I felt my
my son you know start kicking in her
belly
it made me extremely emotional I cried
so earlier today when my friend was
explaining her ideas of a project she
has and I felt that it was beautiful
with the passion that she felt and the
desire when she expressed it so I kind
of teared up a little bit I think my dad
who just found out has early onset
Alzheimer's and so father-son
relationships right now kind of tears at
me it's a tough time right now
old people being lonely probably it's
probably negative saddest the quickest
that's how my cry was two months ago
it was like random because I was going
through depression so it was random so
that summer when I listen to music and
decide stuff I cry then Holocene by
bunny very yeah I mean I haven't cried
out it could be could be anything right
could be tears of joy
yeah can be sadness happiness I'm gonna
probably cry when I see my mom to be
honest I haven't seen her in like three
years
pretty soon probably like two months
she's in Africa right now so no got a
really nice with the woman that gave
birth to me probably see my mama cry I
don't want to see that that's probably a
heart like thing for me broadly when my
brother is really really really sad Oh
is your brother
yeah I'm crying a couple times one
dollar would always stand out is I it
was it was a you know some family issues
I guess and it's it was I was new in the
country and I had to deal with something
hard for my family and you know the fact
that we were by ourselves here it was it
was just difficult you know when you
when you mentioned crying that's one
thing that comes to mind automatically
and my cousin's funeral I'm hearing the
story from my grandpa having watched him
die and so I think I was the last
serious time I agree
dying trees missing someone being
homeless feeling helpless when I left
warm nostalgia what makes me cry
the idea of crying I guess makes me sad
that's when I cried when I saw a cat
that died that I thought that that could
have been my own cat
Beauty makes me cry honestly I'll watch
like an amazing film and I'll have it I
think in a beautiful moment or store
line and I'll cry during that and I
don't think it's less masculine
I love it can you give an example of a
film that made you cry it was unbroken
love Simon I cried six times I can't not
cry during big fish I don't know why
every time I've seen that movie it makes
me cry star is born
I couldn't pursue happiness when I saw
Coco movie romantic comedies generally
can make me at least lose a few tears
Disney movies quite honestly
plain and simple Disney movies and right
now anything I'm in town to say goodbye
to a friend of mine who's has less than
a month to live what I realized recently
is the things that make me cry was when
I'm overwhelmed with love or when I like
the last time I cried I actually was
like hiding from my wife because my dog
had just learned to play hide and seek
and she was looking for me in the house
and trying to come and find me and I saw
her like looking around and that moment
of happiness made me cry I was raised
religiously
[Music]
now an atheist I
[Music]
cry over the fact that just because I'm
honest with both myself and my family
they are incredibly upset about my
beliefs or lack thereof I think there
are many many reasons to cry as a human
and there are many reasons that I cried
nothingness because I'm a believer in
Jesus and Jesus is the word so the only
thing that would make me cry is
nothingness
well the not religion which is it's not
aggressive to the human race
my stomach rod as a good question I
[Music]
honestly can't remember either things
that touch on some sort of a wellspring
of regret or things that make me really
really happy I'm about to lose a
longtime pet and I haven't gotten to
spend very much time with that animal
and I regret that that makes me quite
sad and actually I just got to have my
dad see the pipe organ concert right
here which he's wanted to see for 25
years or something like this it made me
really really happy
most recently what made me cry was the
loss of a dog it was heartbreaking 11
years old my best buddy and we had to
put him down when I talked with my
father and we fix so many problems in
those poor relationship okay that's the
last time I cry for example I was
watching last night on YouTube a little
girl that got found out that she was
getting adopted that brought a tear to
my eye
I was happy tear them my softy when it
comes to that I'm not a machine and
sometimes when I see videos of family
reunions with people from the military
when they come home that that surprise
is very touching to me
I think the fact that not being able to
spend my quality time and most likely
the holidays other people that pass away
already
it brings I think that's what I would
have to say like maybe a few months ago
like it's gonna be like a lot of stuff
it's like work and family and yeah I was
driving and out of nowhere just know I
hate my life and it was kind like a
release it felt a lot better I felt a
lot better afterwards
strangely enough but yeah sometimes you
just need to get that out in order long
last time I cried was actually I think
it was my dad's
birthday my dad's my dad passed away
when I was really young at 8 years old
so my thinking about stuff like that
really hits me hard I have like a
fatherly figure well I mean my father
died when I was 12 so when I talk about
him and tell people what happened and
how he was a man that chokes me up yeah
that's the last time I cried hmm
[Music]
watching the the movie mr. Roberts the
great Henry Fonda William Powell and
Jack Lemmon movie the end where they
find out that mr. Roberts died my father
and I saw that movie when I was young he
was a World War 2 vet so you know
there's a lot of things that are
associated with my dad he died when I
was 12 so we used to watch Barney Miller
together we used to watch mash together
and when those shows had their their
farewell series Enders in 1983 I
couldn't cry my father's funeral and I
don't know why but when those when they
had their final episodes I cried like a
baby and usually I guess I I guess you
could say it's movies but whenever I
want to cry it's always an inappropriate
places like in line at Walmart you know
I I can't seem to cry except when I'm
watching an old program or something
like that
I want to cry I can't do it that sucks
being a man hey guys I just wanna let
you know real quick that I made some new
sweaters and I'm doing a giveaway on my
Instagram so find me on there and follow
the instructions on my most recent post
to enter the instructions are actually
kind of fun I'm having you guys interact
with each other so I hope you enjoyed
that as well other than that I just
really want to thank you guys I want to
thank all the new subscribers I've gone
and the subscribers that have been with
me for a while you guys don't understand
how much fun I have
and it's so cool to have a bigger
audience to share them with so thank you
for that and I think that's pretty much
it I'll see you guys next week
[Music]